[music]
this example shows that it is impossible to
trust not only the verbal statement of the
West, but also the written one, such
hostile actions of Russia will certainly
respond to the
corresponding measures being worked out in an
interdepartmental format and will be taken
in the near future,
their consequences will have a serious
negative impact on the population of lithuania
[music]
pull  what are allowed for from the nose
matte ct france links also pay again with
everyone and I drank study your inside
the winning is off but your glue
[music]
buffer we hope that our mind
will win the madness which hour they are doing
because like most sanctions
this is the measure  it usefully hits the economy of the
Republic of Lithuania, let me remind you that ours
do not make very good money for a colleague to
defeat
[music]